Adam asked me to just kind of give a
quick overview of the beginnings I
actually wasn't there at the beginning
so I can sort of tell it through the
lens that I saw it early on and from
people who saw it who were there at the
beginning I did see some of what
happened pretty close to the beginning
so I ended up being sort of close to the
company before I joined the company I
think there's some real learnings in
kind of how Facebook started and what
the early days were like and I'll talk a
little bit too after that to kind of my
early experience the Facebook when I was
when I did join why I decided to join
kind of what happens with that
so going all the way back to the
beginning probably a lot of people in
the room know the story here already it
it has a lot of the aspects of the kind
of foundation myths that these internet
startups tend to get but what you read
is actually pretty much the truth which
is which is kind of interesting which is
like a lot of the things that became
meaningful on the web on the consumer
web in particular Facebook was started
as a project more than as a company in
the in the early days I know if anybody
was it was a user very early you might
remember it was sort of the about page
of the site it used to say about the
project it wasn't even talking you know
wasn't even thought about as a company
originally and I think there's something
really important to that if you look at
the companies that have had a really
large impact on the consumer web Google
Yahoo eBay Craigslist Wikipedia more or
less kind of the majority of the top 10
names that you would think of as the
things that had a large impact on the
web that's been true pretty broadly now
there's more truth to in some case than
others there's some foundation myth
stuff that comes in there but there is
newly I think a very clear correlation
between things that became really big on
the consumer internet that started out
as projects rather than as companies and
if that Croatian exists and I think
there's a nishan question which is why
why is that the case why is that
Croatian exists I think what it has to
do with is actually a little bit to do
to do with luck and with kind of product
market fit you know it's it's very hard
to make something really big unless it's
really transformative it's obviously
very hard to make something really
transformative if you can look at a
market and do a market mapping and pick
a market segment say I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna do you know you know video
podcasting right because that's it
underserved space once there's a space
and it's well-defined and it's well
understood the chances are it's probably
already too late to do something that's
really transformative so the things that
tend to be really huge tend to come more
from sort of the gut or kind of the
personal passion or beliefs of a founder
who has a vision for you know something
that the world needs now lots of people
are visions for things the world need
and they turn out to be wrong so this is
obviously not a guarantee to success
it's it's it's not a causal relationship
that if you decide you've got something
the world needs that it's necessarily
going to take but I think where the real
magic tends to happen is whether through
luck or through brilliance or some
combination of those two things you
managed to get to a situation where a
founder has a vision for something the
world needs and the world looks at it
and says yeah we agree you know this is
this is something that's really special
I think in a lot of ways that was sort
of what happened with Google what
happened with Yahoo what happened with
Wikipedia would happen with Craigslist
what happened with eBay and what
happened with Facebook and that was kind
of very clear early on as I started to
get to know the company that what was
going on here was something that was
coming from someplace that was really
deep inside the person who had started
it which i think is a really important
thing for the kind of startups that can
really fundamentally change the world in
a better way so you probably know the
early story mark was a sophomore at
Harvard he created this site I think
it's worth spending a minute on mark
because he's a good archetype in a lot
of ways for what makes for a really
great founder there are founders I think
it's very important that founders in a
technical domain have some specific set
of attributes and ideally you can get
more of these together in the same time
it really is really synergistic in the
results that you can get out of it so
the things that tend to matter for
consumer Internet
are it's good of the persons technical
it's good if the person is a product
person so it has a product sensibility a
user Sensibility it's good if the person
has some design capabilities I'm sure
for other markets I don't know anything
about there's other factors that matter
but I'd say in the internet world those
things really matter so you could sort
of summarize I'm saying you want a
product person but you can kind of
decompose that into ideally it's a
technical person product person and a
design person if you combine all three
of those in the same person that's
something that's really really rare and
really special so finding somebody who's
got the ability to not only conceive of
a great product but to build that great
product and to actually design and
implement that product is pretty unusual
and is another thing that I think is
sort of part of what makes for a really
extraordinary outcome if you can get all
the right pieces to align on the right
way and that was Mark and that it's mark
mark mark is someone who's a product
person who definitely had a vision for
something that he wanted to see happen
in the world there were other people of
course who were cofounders of the
company who played a very important role
as well but I think had he not been a
developer and a product person in the
designer kind of all wrapped into one
better at some of those things in others
but you know at least pretty decent at
all them who knows what would have
happened the ability to do that was also
very important for the ability of
Facebook to scale in a way that was
really efficient right from the
beginning so this brings up an
interesting topic that we'll probably
talk about with Kevin a little later but
when Facebook was getting started you
know if you if you rewind a decade and
you probably all know this better than I
do the capital expenditures that were
required to start these kind of
companies and even the effects to create
these kind of companies was very
different than what it looks like today
so when Facebook was getting started
they didn't spend any money on anything
mark and Dustin and Chris didn't spend
any money on anything they didn't spend
any money on servers they didn't spend
any money buying software they of course
didn't spend any money on marketing
because one of the great things about
the model of Facebook is that the user
acquisition cost is zero and the content
acquisition cost is zero which does a
lot for your margins over the long run
and so if you look at what that all
added up to the first three months that
Facebook
as an actual functional production site
anybody have a guess to what the burn
rate was over that three-month period
somebody I know Kevin knows cancel
$1,000 okay it was under $500 and it
what mattered about that was that was
the period in which the product sort of
proved that it had a market fit at least
within the u.s. college market probably
the vast majority of that went to
private and the rest went to buy redbull
but you know the monthly cost was sort
of just paying for virtual colocation
paying for bandwidth paying for kind of
you know virtual virtual server space
essentially all the software of course
was open source all that was free didn't
pay anything for that didn't pay
anything for customer acquisition so
pretty interesting in terms of what that
means for the early economics for
starting these kinds of companies and
again when it was started it it wasn't I
think you know mark is someone who's
done this a few times so when Mark was
in high school he and a guy named Adam
D'Angelo who subsequently joined
Facebook was kind of marks best friend
from back when he was in high school
built a product together that was an
early version of a collaborative
filtering service for music that
basically looked at what music you
listen to look at what music other
people listen to and major
recommendations based on that they
actually got an offer from Microsoft to
buy that from them when they were in
high school and they decide they didn't
want to do that they decided they want
to stay in school and stay focused but
some marks marks history with would that
kind of start at a very early age he
built a couple of other products at
Harvard as well the one that ultimately
really took off was this one but I think
I'm sure he always had sort of you know
business potential in mind from the
get-go
we didn't start Facebook as a company
started Facebook as a dorm room project
and it only became a company later and
so once it was clear that it had some
traction this is about the time that I
got to know mark he said okay this
pretty interesting let's go out to
Silicon Valley this was the summer of
2004 so the site launched initially in
February of 2004 he said let's go out to
Silicon dalek for the summer and just
kind of poke around out there and see
what's happening out there because I've
heard that there's some interesting
stuff
out there and he and Dustin who's the
other co-founder of the company along
with a couple of friends of theirs from
Harvard who were effectively acting as
interns moved out to California and not
long after they got here they decided we
have to stay here you know we're not
going back to school this is a totally
different world than the world that we
knew in Boston and you are all familiar
with what the components are that make
Silicon Valley what it is but the things
that they saw I think in a nutshell were
basically the availability of a
particular type of risk capital here
that that understood these things and
understood the relationship that that
that those investors needed to have to
the entrepreneurs a very entrepreneurial
environment in general of course a
fantastic pool of engineering talent and
other people who were sort of interested
in working at early-stage startups and
then most importantly just like with the
product design and technical things
coming together in one person in the
founder just importantly the combination
of those three things you know there are
other places in the world where you've
got risk capital available this other
place in the world where you've got
great technical talent available there's
other places in the world where you've
got an entrepreneurial mindset I think
to this day even there's no place in the
world where those three things come
together in the way that they do in
Silicon Valley and Mark saw that and
dust and saw that and they said screw
school were dropping out we're here to
stay so they did stay I met mark and for
the first time sort of serendipitously
but by a coincidence I was at LinkedIn
as Kevin mentioned working with a guy
named Reed Hoffman it was kind of been
my mentor in the valley
and Reed and I were up in the city at
the office of guy named Peter teal who
was Reed's old boss at PayPal the guy
who was the founder and CEO of PayPal
talking with Peter about LinkedIn and
Peter said hey you know Sean Parker
who's an old friend of mine who has a
role to play in the story too and this
guy Mark are coming in to to to pitch me
on doing an angel round essentially in
this thing to Facebook why'd you guys
sit in the listen to this so I actually
was was there in the room by a complete
coincidence when Mark first met Peter
Thiel and sort of told him about
Facebook and pitched him on Facebook
mark I she does remember that I was in
the room because I think he was pretty
focused on on Peter
talk about it a lot since I was kind of
a fly on the wall just sort of listing
and what was going on and what was it
about that experience was it really kind
of showed me who mark was and that he
was sort of very genuine and in his
conviction for the product and that you
know this came from someplace that was
really deep in him which was pretty
interesting so after that happened I was
very lucky to start getting pestered by
sean parker who was the first non
founding employee that Facebook hired
think he was technically kind of a third
full-time employee of the company who
was an old friend of mine from the time
that he'd been at plaques and I'd been a
LinkedIn and he called me up and said
hey I really need you to help me
convince this guy I won't say who it was
who was a mutual friend of mine and
Sean's to come join the Facebook to do
business at the Facebook really have to
hire this guy and so I you know I called
him up and I spend a bunch of time
trying to talk him anyway and he didn't
want to do it I thought it was crazy
and kind of through that process I
started thinking huh
maybe I should just go join this company
well I do getting this guy to join this
company but it wasn't really kind of
fully crystallized in my mind because I
was pretty deep in LinkedIn and when
you're you know I was I was I wasn't one
of the founders of LinkedIn but I was
there very early and you sort of get
very deep into what you're doing in
these startups and so I kind of hadn't
really pulled my head up to really see
what else you know what's happening and
it just sort of started coming at me
from a few directions and I was very
lucky that Peter Thiel who was very
close to read and was you know like
they're like read part of this group
that's now called the PayPal mafia was
somebody I had also known through that
group and he said hey what you know he
said a couple months later hey why don't
you come join Facebook and just sort of
help grow it and that point I took a
little bit of a coastal look at it and
I'll touch briefly on kind of what the
two things were that kind of ultimately
made me decide you know what I have to
go do this because think they're sort of
interesting things to look out for
people were thinking about joining a
start-up early so actually there were
three 101 of what you've already talked
about which which was the the founders
and who they were that was sort of a
challenging thing because at the time
mark was was probably 20 and you know I
was working for a guy whose
of these sort of wise men wise people of
Silicon Valley around the consumer
internet has been through a couple of
cycles has you know been doing consumer
internet startups since the mid 90s saw
PayPal through the IPO and the
acquisition and what's that did you ask
social that I don't know that that's
interesting oh that's right button
that's right that's right yeah so his
reads first startup was this company
social net and to go from that to
working for a 20 year old kid who just
dropped out of the software year at
Harvard you know was something that
posed some challenges but I believed in
the person and that was a really
important piece of it and then with the
product there was something really
special going on both quantitatively and
qualitatively quantitatively that the
statistics were unlike anything that I
had ever seen the specific thing that
was really extraordinary was user
behavior over time kind of very broadly
usage increased rather than decreased
and you know the thing you tend to see
with any types of these sites is
basically the question you ask is how
slowly does usage decrease and the
answer to that question here was
actually an increase it doesn't even
decrease and that was just started a
really really unique thing and
qualitatively I was really lucky to have
a younger brother who was a college
student at the time at one of the
schools that was already live on
Facebook as may remember mark started
Harvard and then he expanded it to Yale
and Stanford and then he added a few
more Ivy League schools and kind of kept
expanding out from there it was a
Princeton yeah Princeton yeah you showed
me his profile yeah yeah that's right
that's right
he my brother Luke was a part of the the
early collateral that we used at the
company for talking to be seized and and
talking to marketing people questionable
content which which only served to real
which only served to reinforce that this
was the fundamentals are that people's
lives right it's authentic that's right
actually I think there's not true for
that and all kidding aside and I called
him up and talked about it and talked to
some of his friends about because I
wasn't really tracking this thing
because I hadn't picked in college in a
while
and I said to him hey you know do you
use this thing to Facebook at your
school because you may remember was
called the Facebook then old school
Facebook people still stole
all Facebook the Facebook that's kind of
how you know somebody who you know was
thinking about it early on and the
answer that he gave me was sort of the
most interesting answer I've ever gotten
and that his friends gave me you know I
was expecting them to say yeah of course
sure but they gave me a different kind
of answer they gave me an answer which
was sort of like I can imagine him
sitting in Princeton looking at each
other and and being like who is this
loser like duh you know it's like I'd
asked them like hey do you have
sanitation at Princeton yet you know it
was like inconceivable to them that
someone would ask the question you know
do you use this thing it's like asking
you know if you have sanitation and that
really reinforced me like wow this is
really a very deep part of these
people's lives and you know given the
way the product is construction and in
the technologies constructed this should
scale at least to students probably in
the US and other places where there's a
similar pattern to the US and we saw a
very interesting phenomenon happening
early on in which people were starting
copycat sites of various kinds and the
launching about the schools that we
weren't at yet and nobody was signing up
and we asked around you know asked what
was going on with that and it became
pretty clear that what was happening was
people were waiting for the Facebook to
get there because they had friends who
had been their friends in high school
and family members and other people who
were college students who were already
on the Facebook and they wanted to be
using the same communications platform
the same service that those other people
were useful at the end of the day I was
just sort of very very lucky to be in
the right place at the right time a lot
of things had to line up for it to be
something that that I could go and do it
had to line up with the group of people
involved having a relationship to the
group people I was already working at
with so it wasn't really you know I
wasn't really sort of abandoning this
group of people that that I worked with
him on would work with when I left
LinkedIn
I asked Reid basically for permission to
do it
and the way I put it to him was I said
tell me what you want me to do here you
know if you tell me that if I go and do
this it's going to damage our
long-term working relationship I'm not
gonna do it but if you tell me it's not
I am gonna do it so you know tell me
what I should do when he went away and
thought about it he came back and he
said you should go do it and you know
very lucky that kind of the right
concentric circles were there very lucky
that he is who he is as a person and
that the group of people involved were
who they were as people very lucky to
just kind of be there when the need
existed and that they really had a need
for somebody who fit my profile and to
speak very brief width of that you know
Kevin Kevin mentioned my title I don't
think there's any meaning to that I'll
bet there's 20 people in the room who
know a lot more about product management
than I do really what I've done at
Facebook
Kevin allude to this dilemma too is the
best way I can describe it is I'm not a
founder but I sort of have the type of
role that you'll sometimes see a founder
have when they're not the CEO of the
company I think it helps that you know
timing is a lot to do with those things
and kind of who you are as a person
there's a lot to do with those things
you know I I never had much interest in
in general management and you know it's
great for people who do but if I had had
a passion around it it probably would
have been harder to not focus on those
things and I really would just sort of
wanted to grow the company and that has
a lot to do with kind of you know what
moved to you as a person so I think for
me understanding that about myself was
probably you know the most important
thing and sort of getting comfortable
with that but I do think it's I think
it's an important piece of things for
sure so anyway so bringing up to where
Kevin got involved so we can bring Kevin
back into the conversation know we
definitely know we need to telecom for
the conversation so so I came on board
in early 2005
Excel actually ended up investing in
April of 2005 so Kevin's been involved
with Facebook for you know bad as long
as I have I think it was actually
another piece of serendipity that Excel
was right there on University Avenue I
think you know we actually really liked
that obviously really like the people
and I'll share an anecdote which is just
sort of some color from the early days
of Facebook so you know Kevin was was
being really really aggressive in the
way that a great
he does in you know he believes the
companies want to get into the company
and so you know he was calling he was
practically knocking on doors and I
think eventually at one point he called
me out I remember and said we're coming
down or does coming down I said alright
come on over dammit we're coming over
alright cool come on over so so he came
over and he wanted to bring somebody
else with him and any I think he wanted
to kind of bring a founder with him so
he brought art Patterson who's one of
the the kind of grand old guys that
Excel it's been there a long time along
with him and our first full office on
Emerson Street in Palo Alto was sort of
an interesting place there was some
avant-garde graffiti art up on the wall
there were semi they couldn't blow up on
the walls yep and we were literally just
the process of moving in to the office
we'd been in a house in Menlo Park and
we were just kind of moving into the
first office when they came in so we
were assembling furniture and you know
Kevin and art are so this is a second
story walk-up above where the two
Chinese restaurants are on Emerson
Street if you know where that is right
off University Avenue and so they're
walking up the staircase up up to the
second floor and we're assembling
furniture upstairs so I'd been
assembling some piece of furniture and
it caught my jeans on a nail and my
jeans were kind of ripped open all the
way down my pant leg and and Dustin
Moskovitz was a co-founder of the
company had hit his head on a piece of
perch or was bleeding a little bit from
his forehead so so so Kevin and art walk
up the stairs Kevin's first an art spot
you probably couldn't see him because I
could I could see his face so walking up
the stairs you know art is a incredibly
great you know older guy incredibly
gracious guys looking around he sees
these avant-garde naked people on the
wall and you know he's walking up the
stairs like well what's going on here
they go further up the stairs like dust
in the air you know my jeans are ripped
open halfway and Dustin's literally
bleeding from his forehead and I'm
shouting down the stairs say hey Kevin
and arts just looking up with jaws on
the floor and it's like what the hell am
I doing here
but you know of course there was
something there was something meaningful
going on beyond that but um that that
moment is definitely stuck there I think
I think you have to first look at what
size the company is and what stage the
company is when a company is is really
small and so let's call it five to ten
people certain other things tend to be
there too probably haven't raised a lot
of money may not have either the
business model or the product really
figured out yet man I have to fit
between the product in the market really
figured out yet at that point in time it
is basically just all hands on deck and
I think it would be fair to say that if
we had been talking to people so I don't
have an MBA I actually barely have a
college degree the people who the people
we would have been highly at that point
in time I don't think we would we
certainly wouldn't hold an MBA against
somebody but we wouldn't see it as an as
a significant positive either at that
point in time so at that point in time
all that matters is how scrappy is
somebody you know how quickly can
somebody figure things out how much is
somebody willing to roll up their
sleeves and get stuff done you know the
first week that I was there I remember
we were spending half of our time
everybody in all six or seven people
racking servers in the Colo and that was
the job it's like okay we need to spend
12 hours rocking servers right and
that's it so all that had to get done
because the most important thing for the
company that week that month probably
that part of that year was we need to
keep up with the demand for growth and
the thing that's most constraining that
is our ability to put servers up and for
that we actually said hey let's go hire
some interns to tell about with this
before we had put a full TV on we
actually eventually did that but it
really was sort of the the generalist
skill set to be able to do more or less
whatever you know was really what matter
at that point in time as the company
matures of course those things change so
Microsoft's a partner of ours they're
there they are an investor in the
company we also have a an ongoing
partnership with them in several areas I
think there's a very there's a very kind
of deep respect that exists I can't
speak for Microsoft but certainly from
our side towards Microsoft and from Mark
towards Microsoft go back to that early
anecdote you know Kevin mark calling
Kevin say hey I wanna talk to Bill Gates
a deep respect for the understanding of
platforms that exists at Microsoft and
the way they were able to use that to
build services for people you know Mark
and Ray Ozzie and Bill Gates and the
people or sort of the technology thought
leadership at Microsoft kind of all have
a very very strong relationship and it's
based on those kind of common beliefs in
in those aspects of technology so
there's a very important cultural
affinity at the core there certainly
with Google as well we don't have a
direct you know relationship with Google
of the kind that we have with Microsoft
but it's definitely an organization that
we have a lot of respect for I think
they're they represent a really
interesting phenomenon in in the world
of business in that at some levels we
compete with Google and you know
sometimes I get frustrated because I
just wish you know that that I could get
mad at them you know or kind of deride
them but they're just too damn good for
that you know I mean they're just really
if you talk to the people at Google it's
just they're just really good people and
they're trying to do the right thing and
there's been an interesting shift that's
happened in the market where because the
internet enables so much transparency we
think part of what's going on is
everybody's incentives are actually
aligned with doing the right thing and
with being transparent which is not the
way that business is always operated but
I think that's a shift that actually
will probably go beyond Google hopefully
to kind of affect the world at large but
it's definitely an organization we have
a lot of respect for I think the two
things that that are probably most
important understand about this platform
and platforms in general one is that
when you decide to take a platform
strategy I think a court shift that's
happening for you is you're going from a
zero-sum mindset to a nonzero-sum
mindset what I mean by that is you're
going to mindset where you're saying
it's not about me you know having tight
control over this pie it's about me
enabling the pie to grow as large as
possible and trusting that my share of
that on net is still going to be much
larger than if I just sort of tried to
grip everything too tightly
for myself that ends up affecting the
way you make decisions the way you
prioritize things at some level the kind
of people that you hire so it's a
definite was definitely a very important
thing for us and sort of I wouldn't say
it fundamentally reorient to the company
because it's Kevin touched on earlier I
think internally sort of always a
platform company and mindset but it was
very important for sort of how the
organization evolved and the kinds of
problems that the organization chooses
to address from the perspective of how
we think about it with the product Kevin
touched on this earlier too we we don't
see ourselves really as building a bunch
of applications as much as building a
system that enables people to use what
we've created and sort of make their own
decisions about what information is
important to them what contents
important to them what types of
application I want to use and have our
system really be an enabler for that
more than anything else so over time I
think what you'll see with the platform
is if if we're successful at it it will
enable more and more types of use cases
more and more types of application more
and more types of information sharing
between people to date a lot of what's
happening with the platform has been
about kind of bringing the web into
Facebook and I think what we'll likely
see over the next period of time will be
about continuing to do that but also
about extending facebook out into the
web so that you can take this lens of
the people and relationships that matter
to you
the privacy settings that that enables
the filters on content information that
that enables kind of a view of the world
that that enables and apply it to lots
of different things that you would do on
the internet and we think that's gonna
create a lot of value for people at the
end of the day even even if you think
about it in economic terms if you think
about what drives what the unit driver
is for this type of a business it's
really dated by how many users you have
that matters even more so actually
exponentially more so in a network
effects type of business we're having 10
million people is far more than ten
times more valuable than having one and
I think 100 million is far more than ten
times more valuable than having ten and
so ultimately how much value we can
create is gated by the number of you
that we have you know how connected to
the people that matter to those people
in real life they are on Facebook and so
that's still ultimately sort of a core
focus for us we're happy with how it's
going but if I if I kind of what do I
think about at night I'm thinking about
users and user growth